what if gone had a different Nfinity
seems like a simple change but remember
that Al gon is a very simple boy so
simple changes are going to have
radically character altering effects
think of gone as he is a natural
enhancer so his immediate thought to
that is look I'm going to use my power
to punch things punch things like really
hard whereas as a transmuter or emitter
gone wouldn't be able to fall back on
this option then as a contra or a
manipulator gone would go down some
incredibly different roads especially as
a manipulator we'll cover this in a bit
but being a natural manipulator is gon's
darkest possible outcome and then as a
specialist gon's full potential would be
Unleashed but before we start there are
four very important things to know about
gon one is that again gone is a simple
boy with simple needs and in terms of
nen that makes him much easier to
predict than someone like SE kopa who
has complex needs and even more complex
solutions to said complex needs and this
makes sense because realistically gone
is an 11 to 12year old boy one of the
more realistic portrayals of a child
this age in showna manga so his
Solutions are going to be limited which
is great for us because it limits how
Wild speculation in fact gone himself
within the series provides a
straightforward answer to three out of
the five of Al n affinities the second
thing to keep in mind is that no matter
what Affinity he is gon will always
prefer to be a close-range fighter
that's just who and what he is so
becoming a conjurer isn't all of a
sudden going to transform gone into some
sort of Trixie high IQ nen player the
third thing is his established skill set
gone is a hunter in the classic sense of
the word he has an affinity for nature
and animals and even as a pre-end human
he had heightened senses Vision hearing
smell and even taste taste trained to
the point where he can taste tasteless
substances like tonas laxative and
weirdly enough he also has some poison
resistance implying that he has somehow
tuned his body to poisons this is
important because nen abilities are
built on the foundation of our
experience but also they're built on
desire and so the final thing to
highlight is gon's desire which is
simply to find Jing so no matter what
the Affinity we are looking for
abilities that satisfy these factors and
ideally we want something that satisfies
all of them so with that let's leap into
an alternate world where gone is a
transmuter so as a reminder transmuter
is giving or the properties of other
matter this can be something tangible
and solid like hisoka's bungee gum or
pure more intangible elements like
kila's electricity and this one is super
easy we have a very clear idea of what
gone would have lent towards if he was a
transmuter because the scissors aspect
of J junen is pure transmutation gone
basically created a sender blade ofor
giving it the properties of sharp very
sharp so sharp that it cut through the
Chimera ants and I think that gone
invests heavily into this but also still
retains rock as an optional albeit less
effective attack he would essentially
become a nen swordsman and I think this
makes some sense given gon's experience
after facing hok's bunge gum gon made
believe that blades are the best
possible counter to the gum considering
that he plans on facing and defeating
hisoka in the future and just as rock
evolves scissors would also be enhanced
over time giving them a greater length
greater range greater cut power
depending on the aura invested into them
and he may even become a dual wielder
it's worth noting that the weakness of
scissors is currently the gone would
need to keep the Ora active whereas with
rock you just conjure and punch actually
I suppose gone would probably use
scissors in a similar way he's not
whipping out the blades for an extended
clash it's more for a classic nen
Samurai one strike Victory Honestly
though gone may have had a much easier
time in the series as a natural
transmuter it probably would have
offered better matchups against certain
opponents like gen through for example
in that case he might not have lost his
arm because it gives gone the ability to
fight at close range but without putting
his body so much on the line and it's
also possible that gone may prefer
another type of weapon property to
transmute AA into perhaps something
blunt Pokey or even spiky which I guess
is also Pokey but I guess it can also be
blunt a ma is like blunt and Pokey
doesn't matter to his other neighboring
Affinity imiton becomes a very different
Beast emission is the practice of
separating raw Ora from the user's body
and gone does have one attack that uses
this rock and scissors both remain
heavily in gond but paper is gon's first
dive into a mission and I honestly ly
don't think that this pool goes too much
deeper than that remember simple boy
he's going to go for the Pew pews the
way I picture gone as a natural emitter
is sort of like Razer just without the
complex Greed Island mechanics and the
14 Devils which actually makes gone a
bit more terrifying because his full
force would be going into the key blasts
with that said emission is a really bad
affinity for gone in particular or at
least with how gone would make use of it
and to explain why we need to cut to
some mats knuckle gave some pretty
devastating stats when he stated that
even though gon invested 4,000 units of
Aura into the attack paper only held 500
units worth of output this is due to the
cut that gone takes by using emission in
the first place and also the secondary
cut that comes with separating Aura from
a body because that's an unfortunate
reality emission in general is is just a
painful Affinity because even natural
emitters lose output simply through the
practice of separating their Aura from
their bodies which is why no natural
emitters Deep dive 100% into this
Affinity like we see with literally
every other Affinity most of the series
emitters find themselves splashing in
dual affinities or have to set
conditions to multiply the emissive
powers and even then almost none of them
you straight up throw ball n attacks
think of characters like Melody who emit
Aura through music or even the more
recent Lynch F boo who emits Aura to
make people tell the truth very specific
conditions for very specific outcomes
and there are cases of a mission being
used for straightforward combat but it
really is only CHP tier users like razor
or silver zalic who emit these pure
bursts of destructive Aura and I will
say the one advantage gone does have
here is is natural orur a talent he
definitely has the output to do this if
he wants and as he grows this would only
become more and more dangerous but it's
a big handicap in the early days much
more so than enhancement or
transmutation if you were playing Hunter
Hunter on Hardcore Mode emission is
probably the Affinity you'd want to
start with and it's a particularly bad
one for gone because it just doesn't
operate well on the principle of
Simplicity essentially gon is going to
have a much harder time in the series
than if he was an enhancer or a
transmuter he won't progress as quickly
as he did and he may may be very ill
equipped to handle lots of fights
especially towards the Chimera ant end
of things but now is where things get
very interesting if gone were a natural
conjurer then he would have to rethink
his entire nen strategy because this
takes him far far away from the comfort
of enhancement conjuration is of course
morphing Aura into tangible objects
generally utilized by highly intelligent
strategists like kopa or Henry the
ladder of whom fights with conjured
pigeon objects which is that's pretty
fun but conjuration is also used by cheu
so the the Affinity isn't exclusive to
the sharpest of minds and I think that
gone has another very clear path here
because no he never ventured into
conjuration in the actual series but he
is no stranger to objects and so I feel
like the obvious answer is that gone is
going to conjure a fishing rod and just
as a note in the anime gone never took
his fishing rod to Greed Island however
in the manga he did indeed take it but
gave it away to one of the NPCs and that
was the last time we saw it so I guess
the anime just figured H he's not going
to use it so it's just not included but
as underwhelming as a conj fishing rod
sounds it does satisfy gon's main
criteria one being his natural skill set
all the way up until Greed Island gone
used his Rod as a weapon surprisingly
effective as well for example it was
only thanks to the fishing rod that gone
was able to be gido at Heaven's Arena
and it's a tool he's intimately familiar
with it gives gone a lot of strategic
variance that he sort of lost once he
gave the rod away but it also allows him
options in simplistic combat there are
several cases where gon uses the rod as
a basic Club to just thwack people both
he and the rod had the power to injure
magical beasts and this was before nen
so was a very strong Rod so post nen
what conron does is what all good
Pokémon players do and trade their old
rod for a super rod when it comes to
conjuration the most difficult part is
constructing a mental image detailed
enough to bring into existence but again
a fishing rod is basically an extension
of gon's body he knows it intimately it
is the first and by far most useful
object that would come to mind heavily
enhanced of course much stronger than
your average rod and for classic Hunter
purposes it might come come with some
added utility like making any bait on
the end of it more enticing and if gone
wanted to get real tricky he could even
start coating the line of the rod in E
thus making it invisible sort of like
how kopa conceals his chains you know I
really haven't given gon's intelligence
enough credit in this video but this
sort of thing is his natural element the
fishing rod is a tool of the wild and so
it gives gone access to more instinctual
options having a conjured Rod at his
disposal turns every fight into a hunt
that is gon's territory and I would
genuinely love to see him as a conjur
manipulator gone however I'm not quite
so sure I would want to see although I
will say that it's a surprisingly solid
category for gone especially in the
early days because gon has always
possessed this intrinsic ability to earn
people's trust with great ease and we've
seen examples in the series of this
being accomplished by others with the
use of nen for example Prince Salis Sal
nen Beast this was direct manipulation
you inhale the smoke and then become
infected with favorable thoughts for Mr
salali and I feel like gone would be
similar not a direct manipulator like an
or a Shao more subtle and potentially
not even aware of what he's doing
himself the ability I have in mind is
something I'm going to call Trust seed
which is all about slowly winning people
over to his side say maybe gone does a
favor for the person in question and so
as a result that person has an or seed
implanted into them which works because
gon's neighboring Affinity in this case
would be a mission and as time passes
the seed grows to the point where this
person would do anything for gone
thinking about it from a non-mechanical
perspective it's kind of like using n to
make friends and unlikely to ever reach
a point of 100% manipulation as in
people doing things completely against
their will at the direct command of gone
well except for the following scenario
Chimera at gon is much darker he reaches
a point of Despair where most non- kite
based life is completely meaningless to
him even his own and as his manipulation
ability evolves due to desire he could
find himself manipulating people like
kilawa for his kite agenda which I
imagine as a scenario where kilawa
escapes ilam just to be snared by gone
this is gon's darkest possible potential
as an enhancer transmuter emitter or
even conjurer gone really only has
himself to deal with he made the
decision to sacrifice himself for
Revenge but what would he do in a
situation where his power is to do with
others would he sacrifice them like say
Force killer to evolve into an adult
killer again gun's path in the series in
general would probably be quite rough
because manipulation it's just not
amazing for his fighting style although
it does present the potential of being
able to win simply via his opponent
liking him and thus not wanting to fight
but just like conjuration it takes gone
very far away from enhancement however
unlike conjuration it still leaves gone
weaponless his only real recourse for
like power output would be a mission
which again not an amazing stter either
so manipulation I would say is probably
G's worst possible natural Affinity it's
the one that allows him to do what he
wants to do the least if that makes
sense it may not but then we have the
wild world that is specialist gone the
definition of specialization ation being
whatever doesn't fit into the first five
categories and maybe even some stuff
that does it's the most difficult
category of all for us because literally
anything is possible as long as the user
needs it to be possible K's skill Hunter
was generated as a response to his
profession as a thief and need for
multikill sets and pako's memory reading
was developed in response for the need
to confirm sasa's Killers you know what
neito is a great example actually
someone who we can sort of compare with
gone the desire to want to fight kite
again led to the puppeteering power and
Pito is a deeply instinctual life form
who operates without too much
unnecessarily complex thought like gone
the unfortunate thing is that what most
Specialists have in common is that their
abilities are quite complex na nrad
ridik or even ARA wish granting is
simple sounding but it comes with a
whole ton of nen rules to obey unless
you're kilawa and you know weirdly
enough from all the examples we have I
would see Gone Going Down the more sidik
route not with all the crazy future
stuff but because sidik is the only
specialist whose ability focuses on his
environment which is very natural for
gone to be doing to perhaps heighten his
awareness of everything around him so
we'll call this ability hunting grounds
and maybe it allows gone to perceive
time passing more slowly so that he can
take in more of his environment or even
something like enhancing his senses
perhaps even affecting the environment
itself to produce more of what gives
gone information whether that's sight
smell or sound but all within a special
zone so whatever the case hunting
grounds gives gone a sick sense of
whoever or whatever steps into it like a
very specialized n although gone could
also use his specialization to develop
any of the abilities we've discussed so
far would that be a good use of
specialization no would it be simple
though yes but let me know in the
comments what do you think gon's n
ability would be if he had a different
natural affinity